I am the Kelly goleta the
secretary-general of the International
Federation of Red Cross Red Crescent
Societies I'd be speaking to your
laundry forum blog I will be speaking to
you on Africa Africa use the youth in
Africa you have an opportunity today you
are you have you have an opportunity of
the world because the world is changing
and in this change the challenges are
very clearly identified the solutions
are very clearly identified but the
implementation is lagging behind because
the the generation before you and the
generation before them as well he is
struggling on the implementation from
the weight of culture the weight over
the past now you are the new generation
you know the challenge you know the
problems there are the solutions you
can't push implementation without having
the weight of the past now go forward
don't wait for us the conflicts have to
give his own food problems in Africa
will have to be resolved there is a new
technology the technology can provide
you with solutions today therefore go
ahead and work on improving your future
you can do it and it is doable please go
ahead and do it